the definition of : ology is literally
the blending of culinary arts with food
science and technology the chef's that
are crafting the executions are briefed
to mimic what's out there in restaurants
and then create alternative executions
based upon their own culinary creativity
when those get evaluated
it's a cross-functional team of
marketing our food scientists our
executives and we'll bring the consumers
in and actually have them taste what we
identified as the gold standard so it's
made to be what gold standard is exactly
it's the target of what you want the
final execution to be sort of final
mass-produced product should match this
bench top gold standard flavor this is a
perfect transition to the cheesy garlic
bread Jesus parmesan and this is all
about layering flavors again mozzarella
cheddar and one more smoked gouda oh so
we have raw garlic we have sweet pureed
garlic and got chili flakes in there we
got some black pepper in there and that
is the culinary gold standard execution
that became the final flavor experience
for cheesy garlic bread once that dish
leaves your kitchen what happens after
so once we've identified the flavor
experience the seasoning scientists
start working with their tools to
recreate that experience but inevitably
they come back to us and we evaluate it
as a group alongside the gold standard
that inspired it how do you know if
you've got it
you're gonna find when you taste this
and taste the chip that the flavors are
identical but the experience and
emotions that they evoke are also
identical we don't want to just sell you
potato chip with seasoning on it
three different types of garlic four
different types of cheese this has the
right elements to give you a dynamic
multi-flavored experience but at the
same time and let you feel like you're
eating little comfort that is cheesy
garlic bread I'm gonna try to chip mmm
very similar I hope so